vamos ahora con el problema 63 en el
problema 63 dice que carlota puede
manejar de su casa a la oficina por una
de dos posibles rutas y además cuando
regresa también debe tomar algunas de
esas rutas y lo que nos preguntan es la
distancia de la ruta más corta entonces
en el dibujo más o menos yo creo que por
aquí está la casa de carlota por aquí
está su oficina y tenemos que hay una
ruta larga que yo creo que es porque
tiene muchas curvas y una ruta corta
déjame ponerle a la ruta a la longitud
de la ruta larga l ya la longitud de la
ruta corta pues p de pequeña porque ya
use para casa vale entonces vamos a ver
bueno lo que nos preguntan es cuál es la
longitud de la ruta corta de pep y vamos
a ver qué información nos dan en el
inciso 1 nos dice que cuando cuando
maneja de la casa a la oficina por la
ruta corta y regresa por la ruta larga
entonces maneja un total de 42
kilómetros es decir qué
más él es igual a 42 esto por sí mismo
no es suficiente para determinar el
valor de p porque no sabemos nada acerca
de él vamos a ver si eso lo podemos
juntar con el inciso 2 para decir algo
interesante en el inciso 2 nos dice que
cuando maneja de ida y de regreso usando
la ruta larga entonces maneja en total
46 kilómetros es decir si hace esto y
estos son 46 kilómetros es decir 12 l es
igual a 46 va a 46 kilómetros bueno otra
vez por sí mismo este inciso no nos
permite decir nada acerca de p porque
sólo habla de él pero con este inciso
podemos despejar el l sería igual a 23 y
ahora a 23 a 23 y ahora podríamos
sustituir aquí arriba el valor de l para
determinar el valor de p
tenemos que p 23 es igual a 42 a 42 y
por lo tanto p es igual a 21 si restando
23 de ambos lados entonces juntando la
información de los dos incisos podemos
responder la pregunta
pero ninguno por separado la responde
entonces la respuesta es sí vamos ahora
el problema 64 problema 64 en el
problema 64 simplemente nos piden
determinar si x le gana a ye en el
inciso 1 de información nos dicen que x
es igual a más 2 x es igual a más 2 a
ver pues aquí nos está diciendo que no
importa qué valor tengáis x siempre va a
ser dos unidades más grande entonces
pues aquí sí tenemos que x le gana de
verdad yemas 2 siempre le gana allí
entonces x le gana allí el inciso 1 por
sí mismo es suficiente ahora vamos a ver
qué dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos
dicen que x entre 2 x entre 2 es igual a
menos uno en este de aquí no está tan
claro verdad lo que voy a hacer es pasar
el 2 multiplicando esto lo que nos dicen
es que x es igual a 2 y menos 2
2 y ahora y ahora pues vamos a probar
algunos valores de x a ver qué pasa o
mejor valores de y a ver si es igual a
cero si es igual a cero
entonces x es igual a menos 2 entonces x
es igual a menos 2 y si es igual a pues
algo grande digamos 10 x es igual a 18
entonces aquí arriba ya le ganó a x y
aquí abajo x le ganó h
entonces la información del inciso 2
pues no es suficiente para determinar si
se da esta igualdad o no verdad le voy a
poner una tache entonces la respuesta
sería a
muy bien vamos ahora el problema 65 en
el problema 65 nos bueno nos dicen que
me es entero m es entero
y nos preguntan si m es impar m es impar
es impar ok vamos a ver que nos dan de
posibilidades de información en el
inciso 1 del inciso 1
nos dicen que m entre 2 no es un entero
par m entre 2 no lo ponen en grande no
es un entero
entero para qué condición tan más rara
pero yo digo que no nos dice mucho
o sea que algo no sea un entero par pues
puede ser que sea porque no es entero o
porque es un entero impar entonces por
ejemplo si tomamos no sé m igual a 1 en
mí igual a uno pues m entre 2 es igual a
un medio que no es un entero impar estoy
aquí no es un entero impar pero si m es
igual no sé digamos a que le pondré 6 o
10 entonces m entre 2 es igual a 5 que
tampoco es un entero par vale pero esto
pues no nos dice si m es pero si es
impar por ejemplo aquí m sin para quién
es para entonces no podemos determinar
la variedad de m simplemente sabiendo
esta condición tan rara entonces le voy
a poner tache vamos al 2 en el 2 nos
dice que m
3m -3
un entero para un entero par pues esto
sí es mucha más información verdad
porque nos están diciendo que un número
a tres de distancia es un entero para
entonces m m que consiste de a m
3 sumarle 3 debe ser impar porque
estamos sumando par con impar m3 que es
par si le sumamos 3 que es impar nos
queda impar no podemos pensar de varias
formas por ejemplo si tenemos aquí un
número equis y es el número x es no sé
digamos par
y voy a poner aquí que es par o no sabes
que le voy a poner que es mejor impar le
voy a poner que es impar
entonces si tenemos este entero x que es
impar pues x + 1 x 2 x 3 serían
alternadamente para dar impar
y par y si vamos para el otro lado
tenemos que x1 y x2 y x menos 3 pues
también serían alternadamente par en par
en par y par es una idea muy sencilla
verdad simplemente los enteros van
alternando su paridad cuando vamos
avanzando de uno en uno entonces si
sabemos que x menos 3 es un entero par
tenemos que x es un entero impar vale
bueno entonces esta información es
suficiente por sí misma y por lo tanto
la respuesta es b va ahora vamos al
problema al problema 66 y en el 66 tengo
que hacer un dibujo entonces deja de
poner por aquí el dibujo
tenemos un triángulo que lo hacen muy
derechito intentaré intentar que me
quede más o menos igual y que parece
simétrico va entonces ahí está el
triángulo aquí marcan que el ángulo es
de 90 grados que este vértice es a que
el día que arribe se ve el de acá ese
que esté piel pierde la altura es de y
que este ángulo de aquí es x x grados
diseños y lo que queremos hacer es
determinar el área
el área del triángulo bueno el área es
la mitad de la base por la altura vamos
a ver si la información que nos da pues
contempla un poco acerca de esto
entonces en el inciso 1 nos dicen que
bebe x ac es igual a 20 b de x ac es
igual a 20 que se está geométricamente b
de verde es la altura y mira hace es la
base entonces aquí nos están diciendo el
producto de la base con la altura y nos
dicen que es igual a 20 y de aquí
fácilmente podemos determinar el área
verdad simplemente tenemos que
determinar entre 2 que dividir entre 2
perdón que determinar eso que tenemos
que dividir entre 2 nos quedaría que el
área es igual a 10 vale entonces este
inciso es súper bueno para determinar el
área vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en
el inciso 2 del inciso 2 nos dicen que x
es igual a 45 45 esto está raro verdad
que este ángulo es 45 pues a lo mejor
podemos determinar un poquito de los
ángulos esto es de 90 este de aquí
arriba es de 45
y creo que no podemos hacer nada más
pero saber pues que este ángulo es de 45
90 45 ni siquiera nos dice nada acerca
de las longitudes entonces seguro aquí
no tenemos nada de esperanza de
determinar el área entonces pues
únicamente funciona el inciso 1 la
respuesta sería a lo voy a poner más acá
la respuesta sería a muy bien y ahora el
problema 67 problemas 67 en el problema
67 nos piden determinar el valor debe
más se nos piden determinar el valor de
bmc y la información que nos dan es en
el inciso 1 que a b
además cede más hace vd hace vd
bd es igual aceite seguro aquí no
tenemos chance de encontrar el valor
debe más de verdad porque tenemos estas
variables hay de que estorban lo que yo
creo es que combinando esto con
información del inciso 2 qué problema
que probablemente va a ser de a y de
vamos a poder responder la pregunta
entonces vamos a ver qué dice el inciso
2 el inciso 2 dice que además de
es igual a 4 eso es justo lo que
esperábamos verdad bueno primero hay que
darnos cuenta que el inciso 2 por sí
mismo pues no nos dice nada de bmc ahora
sí lo que podemos hacer lo que podemos
intentar hacer es combinar los dos
incisos que yo creo que tiene que ver
con factorizar este lado a ver vamos a
ver qué pasa si lo intentamos factorizar
aquí tenemos a b y hace entonces voy a
factorizar déjame tomar otro color
voy a factorizar este término y este
término vale entonces nos quedaría a x b
mazén
a x ve más y ahora voy a pasar a este
término y este término más más de d es
el término común x se ve pero podemos
cambiar el orden además de saleh tenemos
esta expresión y ahora voy a factorizar
la voy a factorizar la una vez más
porque tenemos el término como un bmc y
entonces lo puedo poner como además de
x ve más si si no me crees puedes seguir
los pasos al revés este lo desarrollas
primero a este utilizando la propiedad
distributiva y luego a este utilizando
la propiedad distributiva otras dos
veces pero bueno el chiste es que esta
expresión de la izquierda es a más de
por bmc sabemos que esto de aquí es
igual a 6 y juntando esto con la
información de del inciso 2 sabemos que
además de es igual a 4 y por lo tanto
bmc es igual a 6 entre entre 4
dividiendo entre 4 de ambos lados que es
igual a 3 medios entonces determinamos
el valor de bmc eso no era lo importante
lo importante es saber que combinando la
información de los dos incisos podemos
responder la pregunta y por lo tanto la
respuesta de este inciso es c